die hero leider was geht ab max und
herzlich willkommen zu göttern wir
machen wieder eine kleine change und
zwar die super secret settings change
wann immer ich sterbe muss ich mir ein
super secret setting drauf klatschen und
wir dürfen wahrscheinlich alle die super
series in minecraft kennen sie können
ziemlich ätzend sein
deshalb hoffe ich mal dass ich nicht
allzu häufig sterben werde und bist okay
es ist super setting oh gott das ist der
ok das ist echt nicht ich weiß ja wie
colin blogger aussehen wie soll das denn
schaffen
ok ich kann natürlich mir überlegen dass
ich mich geplant umbringe denke ich mal
dass wenn ich diese dies wenn die
settings zu hart sind als dass ich
irgendwas checke ich glaube dass ihr
wissen ob man kann echt nichts mehr
unterscheiden
oh gott was habe ich mir da angetan wie
sehen denn die keulen blöcke aus leute
das wird schwierig das ist glaube ich
eine ach so ja genau und natürlich wenn
man diese passive settings aktiviert hat
ja okay so sehen die art perfekt dann
weiß ich jetzt
wenn man super sieht settings aktiviert
habt dann geht ob tief 1 nicht mehr und
war das 1 1 perfekt
das hier ist glaube ich auch wieder
einer es ist richtig schwierig aber ich
habe eigentlich schon relativ gut
cornberg gesammelt muss ich sagen also
67 stück habe ich ja schon
und wie sagt man so schön 67 stück ist
besser als nichts
wer kennt das sprichwort diesmal weiter
gucken das ist nicht dabei bleibt oh
gott nein ich war so kurz vorm vom ziel
ist das gar kein so dickes tagen werde
ich nochmal oder war das gerade einfach
normal vielleicht ist es einfach nur
glück gewesen dass jetzt keines mehr
habe oder deaktiviert man mit dem
nächsten klick immer das sieht irgendwie
aus wie lsd dabei spielen wir gar nicht
die karte lsd sondern das ist einfach
nur
krank o'shea zum glück nein es ist kopf
über die points habe ich bin was ich bin
bei smart 419 collins und der andere
einfach 820 der gerade gewann hat ihr
spiel wie lsd ich glaube das klügste
wird sein
ich bring dich um also so kann man nicht
spielen
neues setting alles besser als gerade
eben o mein gott leute das ist so hart
kann man hier überhaupt die details
erkennen die die cornberger gott da war
glaub ich gerade einer was ist das was
ist das okay ich bin gestorben
nein ich hab so wenig kann blöcke leute
das ist nicht gut ich finde die auch
schick ist eigentlich mega gut bei dem
ding also sie voll cool aus aber zurzeit
voll umsetzt
deshalb weil ich glaube dass das echten
die versprechen ich werde allerdings im
deathmatch das zeug wieder raus nehmen
und gott oh gott
okay das ist mir wurscht er ist sind
aber auch wirklich wie in köln werke
darunter ist eine wahrscheinlich finde
ich die gleiche einer einer einer das
game wird nicht einen sondern hier ist
ein problem das zählt jetzt einfach mal
hat es zwar grad kein super setting aber
es ist halt einfach sagen wir mal
zufällig deaktiviert ich weiß nicht
genau wie das wieder wie das
funktioniert bei super secret settings
aber ich bin einfach sehr froh darüber
dass es bleib mal kurz nicht da ist und
ich wenigstens ein paar points sammeln
kann
das hat wehgetan dass ich heute meinen
facebook wie mario spielen
und ich hab so unglaublich wenig konz
und es ist einfach als wenn ich
betrunken weniger ausnahmsweise mal
nicht keine angst leute als coach
das ist so das ist irgendwie so der der
kater filter leute das wird absolute
krise das ist entspannt so kann man es
wirklich spielen das gradmesser andere
hatte ja auch irgendwie so diese optik
aber das war noch ein bisschen
behinderter weil man irgendwie im
verschwommen gesehen hat
zack zack zack und immer wieder kommen
doch in 3500 jahren angesammelt ja ich
bin unkonzentriert auch noch perfekter
zu kirche tochter
die sind einfach nur schwarz jetzt das
heißt es ist komplett random ob ich eine
fliege oder nicht ist ja so dumm
wobei ich könnte auf drei aktive da
steht ja immer was für ein blog man
gerade anschaut
aber es findet vor allem gleich einer
auch verdammt
oh gott leute die mit phase ist vorbei
ich wenn ich wissen wie wenig ab 538
gramm leute mit 1500 coins hier drin
oh gott was ich mir jetzt kaufen erst
mal einen level das jetzt tun müssen
oh gott es ist so schwierig
eine angel ist gut damit kann ich
vielleicht irgendwas anstellen wobei
aber als relativ teuer und zu guter
letzt einfach drei gold erzählen jetzt
habe ich eine abschreibung größtenteils
eingekauft gut mir noch irgendwie
schadens darauf bringen auf das schwert
geht dafür muss ich erst mal an der b1
stand kriegen das dauerte immer ein
bisschen aber ich weiß nicht ich bin
zwar nicht so super eingespielt aber die
challenger hat sich ziemlich in sich
also ich hatte mindestens 34 filter wo
ich einfach was ich meinen chancen
irgendwann collenberg zu finden so
immens verringert haben oder weil ein
statement an breaking nehme ich lieber
nicht mit
dann nämlich über gar keins mittels an
breaking dawn part i werde ich
wahrscheinlich noch eine teil straße
gewesen dass er noch verdammt ich bin so
dumme leute das wird jetzt richtig
richtig schwierig wahrscheinlich gibt es
auch noch welche die irgendwie
wasserläufer oder sowas haben auf der
karte der typ da vorne hatte er über das
man kann vor allen dingen dass es so
hart wenn man ohne linksfuß wenn man
geht der hatten entscheidet das eisen
schwertfisch oder die besser gesagt okay
das ist aber gut die ist könnte könnte
eigentlich schlimmer kommen also auf der
karte ist eine angel schon echt relativ
gut dass kämpft ihr gegen andern dann
kann ich vielleicht abstauben ist die
festliche schwerter handel
und perfekt stellt erst mal geholt ui ui
renn renn renn renn
okay wir müssen uns irgendwie
durchschmoren dass es schaffen science
und ich dachte irgendwie okay oder so
der gegner vor allem guckt euch das an
die sind einfach alle full die ja so ist
das glaube ich auch normalen der
regulären gestern runde und man selbst
merkt dass einfach nur wenn man kürzt
einem natalia auch richtig fast gaz
medias auf jeden fall habe ich sind ja
echt spaß so du kannst jetzt erst mal zu
mir und dann kann ich vielleicht
abstauben kürzt einem max ursula klein
riesa klein vor der macht macht base
thermisch weg mit dir ich muss oder
wasser gold apfelwein oder das ist eine
harte change wirklich vor allen dingen
weil man echt echt nachteile hat was das
angeht vor allem feier ist fertig das
wäre jetzt ein richtig schlechtes wetter
holzschwert ist kollege kann ich da
runter holen wenn du willst wird es
geschehen coach ich bin verloren
ich bin verloren wert wasserläufer
krass leute ich glaube das war's da kann
man nichts gegen machen wenn jemand
wasser läuft und du auch noch schlecht
ist wird man das hier bin zwar eine gute
kommen rein gedrückt weil wir den ist ja
auch ein paar mitnimmt kann sie nicht
tun läuft was er hat einfach entweder
hatte ihn gerade es oft nicht getroffen
oder der andere hat base gehackt deren
anosmie klappt jetzt schaffens und
wasser und fach
naja ok ich glaube es war relativ
unterhaltsam meine stimmt immer ein
bisschen weh weil ich mich gerade so
umgehauen habe und ja dann bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss